this gives new meaning to the term
drawing blood at number nine artist Ted
Lawson has hacked a machine to produce a
self-portrait printed in blood ted has
literally put his blood into his artwork
that is intense
forget duck faces and throw away your
selfie stick
Ted is taking the selfie to a whole new
level
I can't imagine Kim Kardashian doing
this yeah we went to Brooklyn to see his
bleeding edge technique first and I
personally am NOT a big fan of self of
doing self-portraits and certainly not
getting nude for a self portrait
the idea was too interesting to pass it
up and a hack together this Russian ink
device and I realized that I could
actually hook the Machine up directly to
my own blood supply talk about blood
sweat and tears
how is Ted created this incredible
printer to make his picture Ted first
took a photograph of himself and then
use the computer to process that
photograph into a series of geometric
shapes that can be lined wrong they can
then take that and you can put it into a
CNC machine basically computer numeric
control and then the machine knows
exactly to make to create his final
drawing Chad may have turned himself
into a fountain pen but is losing this
much blood safe the average man has
about 12 pints or 6 liters of blood in
his body and even though this piece of
art is very large the total amount of
blood being used is not all that much
while making one picture
Ted estimates that he uses less than a
pint or less than half a liter of blood
so Ted is fine but does blood make a
good ink the first challenge that Ted
needs to meet is the tendency of his
blood to clot up the reasoning of what
does that is because it's trying to stop
the hemorrhaging one way of getting
around this C is to make sure the blood
keeps moving and that you've got a big
enough needle for it to comfortably flow
through what's very interesting is that
Ted has found that no two pictures are
alike the quality and consistency of his
own blood changes over the course of the
day which made
had to be constantly adjusting his
machine to get the right kind of blood
flow for the effect that he was after
your blood changes a lot throughout the
day sometimes it comes out too light or
too faint or it's too thin and you'll
have to go back and work on those live
with a constantly replenishing supply of
ink ted offers to create another
portrait oh my god Ted made a portrait
of me that's incredible
yes Debbie it is incredible our very own
Mona Lisa in blood